a rare event in space will bring a dark
day for millions of Americans but many
see it as a cause for celebration
scientists and citizens alike are
preparing for August 21st
that's when a total solar eclipse will
cross North America for the first time
in 99 years it will start in Oregon and
take less than two hours to reach South
Carolina Adriana Diaz is in makanda
Illinois which will be directly in the
Eclipse path Adriana good morning good
morning yep we are in the eclipses path
all right look at this they even painted
a line along where the Eclipse will
cross town now don't let this town's
population of just 600 people fool you
makanda will be the place to be in
exactly two months as one of the areas
where the Eclipse can be viewed the
longest for more than two minutes you
feel lucky
I do feel lucky how can you not feel
lucky this is a lucky event the solar
eclipses path runs straight through Dave
Dardis says art studio and shop in
makanda Illinois and friends are coming
out of the woodwork to get in on the
action
they're wondering is the room in your
backyard if they're good friends i tom
bring your sleeping bag there's room
tens of thousands of people are expected
to pour into the region
Joe McFarland calls himself the town's
unofficial Eclipse coordinator what it
means is that we're nervous that we're
going to have crowd control issues
traffic control issues but we are trying
to prepare for that on August 21st the
eclipse will race across the country at
an average speed of about 1500 miles an
hour covering a swath of roughly 70
miles wide day will turn in tonight and
temperatures will drop as much as 25
degrees and everyone all around you has
the sense this feeling of awe as they're
watching this really incredible
experience macand is just one of the
many places along the eclipses path
where scientists will also gather to
collect rare data on the Sun and the
earth we're going to be looking at the
changes in the clouds temperature light
as well as how our animals in
plants going to respond to this looking
skyward the eclipse will give spectators
their only chance to view the sun's
lower Corona that area expels
electromagnetic energy and matter into
the solar system which can have a
real-world impact here on earth it
messes with GPS with communication
systems even power grids as for makanda
this area is the only place in the
country that will get not one but two
solar eclipses the second will be in
2024 how do you feel knowing you'll
experience it twice if I'm still alright
I think that'll be quite great now if
you're thinking of coming out for the
big event I'm sorry to say it might be
too late
many hotels and prime viewing spots are
reportedly sold out across the country
and locals here tell us that one room is
fetching as much as $3,800 Jeff Adriana
thank you very much